[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine silvester torte die
könnte wirklich wunderbar zu bereiten
für eure silvesterparty
und zwar habe ich einen trip cache
gemacht also eine torte mit dieser glas
wo oben drüber die sonnenbrand
unterläuft und mir ist beten immer ganz
wichtig dass er an erster stelle gut
schmecken
hier habe ich im inneren wandel böden
habe ein orange shirt und in der mitte
habe ich jenny belize versteckt und ich
glaube die torte ist vom
schwierigkeitsgrad her schon so dass sie
danach machen kann
ich stehe jetzt zuerst einmal mit dem
teig und zeigt euch die zutaten für den
teig verwende ich sechs eier 300 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas wandel
extrakt eine prise tonkabohne 300 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 200 gramm wasser 100
gramm naturjoghurt dann nämlich weder
den zehnprozentigen 200 gramm mandeln
die werde ich jetzt gleich noch mal 400
gramm mehl infekt dem backpulver und ein
paar zucker streute ich gebe jetzt doch
erst die eier in die rührschüssel und
wenn die eier zimmer war ein bisschen
lassen sie sich viel besser aufschlagen
da kommt jetzt der zucker dazu etwas
salz und da kann ich die eier
zuckermasse für etwa 15 minuten richtig
schön weiß schaumig schlagen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die eier zucker wasser
aus da kommt jetzt ein bisschen
tonkabohne rhein ein richtig tolles
gewürz es wird jetzt ein bisschen dazu
gewannen
dann kommen da jetzt die flüssigkeiten
rein also das wie du und ich weg
übrigens immer alles auf der waage ab
deswegen bestehen bei mir bei den
rezepten auch immer mit gramm angaben
zum beispiel auch beim öl oder beim
wasser weil man so hat wirklich nur die
eine waage hat und kein missbrauch
bevor der joghurt dazu kommt versuche
ich dir noch kurz schön glatt
[Musik]
dann das mineralwasser als er mit
sprudel dazu und kurz die zutaten
einigung
[Musik]
die mantel habe ich ja auch schon
gemahlen
das mache ich mal ganz gerne weil die so
ihr volles aroma noch haben die kommen
jetzt dazu gemeinsam mit mehl und
backpulver
jetzt kommt der teig eben meine zwei
backform lichtpaket in zwei tortenring
damit sein noch schneller backt und die
habe ich bereits auf 24 cm eingestellt
die hälfte da rein die hälfte dort rein
und ab in den backofen
aber ihr könnt den teig natürlich auch
in einer backform backen aber dann
verlängerte fall die backzeit um zu
testen um der zeit gleichmäßig
aufgeteilt auf zwei plattformen könnt
ihr einfach zahnstocher nehmen den einen
hier reinstecken den anderen da rein so
wie beim auto wenn man das öl ist dann
nebeneinander halten und hier sieht man
jetzt fast gleich hier ein bisschen noch
nehmen darüber und dann passt
ab in den ofen
[Musik]
während der teig im ofen ist kann ich
schon mal die füllung machen ich werde
seinen sport machen also eine abwandlung
von einem level curt für das orion stört
verwende ich vier unbehandelte orangen
davon brauche ich 200 milliliter saft
100 gramm zucker einen teelöffel stärke
jeweils eine prise carter beim salz und
zimt etwas vanille extrakt vier eier
etwas muskatnuss und 60 gramm butter ist
nämlich die orangen die sind bereits
heiß abgewaschen und davon kommt jetzt
die orangenschale in den topf
[Musik]
beim porsche schreiben oder beim zitrone
reiben ist eigentlich nur wichtig dass
der weiße teil nicht mit geräten wird
also wirklich nur die orangenschale
dafür einfach nur ganz locker über die
reise gehen und so hat man das schöne
aroma ohne bittere stoffe
hier habe ich jetzt direkt noch ein
bisschen muskatnuss dazu und jetzt den
saft auspressen und davon 200 milliliter
direkt in den raum
auch hier nämlich einfach wieder die
küchenwaage und kann 200 gramm abmessen
[Musik]
kommen hier noch die übrigen zutaten
dazu also die eier dann schön verrühren
und am besten nicht kleckern riesling
jetzt was man nicht
beim zucker zimt salz und karbon und die
gewürze sind natürlich optional wenn ihr
jetzt ziemlich kardamom oder auch
muskatnuss nicht mit blas zweck habe es
ja wirklich nur eine ganz kleine prise
von allem und das hebt noch mal den
orangengeschmack richtig schön und macht
dir dieses organs köln einfach so ein
bisschen winterlich und jetzt einfach
den herd auf mittlere stufe stellen und
das orange kürze ein bisschen eindecken
lassen
das ist doch ganz kurz aufkochen mir ist
einfach den herd auf mittlere stufe
stellen und dann während dem berühren
das level orange geld eindecken lassen
und einmal kurz aufkochen lassen
es ist dennoch aufpassen denn wenn das
klappt dann kann es mit gebt den herd
ausmachen und die butter einrühren und
die butter sorgt jetzt dafür dass das
ganze richtig schön cremig herzen im
kühlschrank wird es dann wieder fest und
dadurch wird auch schön streichfähig
jetzt streiche ich das ganze durch ein
haarsieb ich nehme da jetzt das fleißige
lieschen dann muss ich nämlich nicht
selber mit löffel durch streichen
jetzt könnt ihr die kühe zeit des
körpers auch nutzen und schon mal die
creme zu bereiten für die creme verwende
ich 200 gramm weiße schokolade 500 gramm
sahne 500 gramm mascarpone etwas manila
extrakt und salat
die schokolade wird jetzt fein gerieben
oder gehackt die muss ich nämlich
schmelzen
[Musik]
und später brauche ich für den trip noch
mal weiße schokolade also kann ich dir
jetzt auch gleich schreiben dann kann
ich mir nämlich den abwasch sparen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die heiße sonne und
gießt es sie über die weiße schokolade
und dann kann ich das gleich wenn es ein
bisschen abgekühlt ist auch in den
kühlschrank stellen damit alles schön
abkühlt und später dann die creme
zusammenrühren schließlich hier die
übrige sahne rein
so kühlt das ganze nämlich ein bisschen
schneller ab deswegen habe ich auch
nicht die komplette sahne aufkochen
lassen
jetzt kann ich es abdecken und in den
kühlschrank stellen bis es wieder
richtig schön auf kühlschranktemperatur
abgekühlt ist und dann können wir später
die creme fertigstellen
ich habe ich ja noch ein bisschen zeit
und kann mich um die deko kümmern
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier ein paar
kate opfer also ein bisschen deko für
die oberfläche der torte und dafür hab
ich weiße blüten passte genommen und
bereits ein paar tag vorher schon
geknetet und dann eben diese zahlen
geformt ihr nehmt ihr weiße blüten
passte knetet sie weich und rollte dann
zu einem langen strang und dann könnte
beliebig zahlen oder zum beispiel auch
buchstaben legen und die dann an den
verbindungsstellen ein bisschen
zusammenkleben mit s-bahn kleber damit
sie später auf der torte befestigt
werden können kommen unten noch
zahnstocher rein die werden auch rein
geklebt und dann dürfen die elemente
einfach ein paar tage aushärten
so wie ich hier und ich nehme die jetzt
und besprühte einfach noch mit etwas
metallic screen zu bekommen sie eine
schöne farbe erst die rückseite dann
trocknen lassen dann die vorderseite
[Musik]
ich habe ich die tortenböden
durchgeschnitten jetzt kann ich die
creme zubereiten bzw fertigstellen
dafür einfach kurz die mascarpone mit
ein bisschen vanille extrakt cremig
rühren
[Musik]
jetzt gießt hier langsam die abgekühlte
schoko sahne dazu bei niedriger stufe
ich weiß sonst klettern
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier langsam auf das
sommerbad dazu und dann kann ich die
creme steif schlagen
jetzt nämlich die tortenböden den
obersten lasse ich jetzt erst mal weg
und werde jetzt hier damit ich in
surprise verein bekomme ein loch durch
stechen
das heißt alle mal kurz aufeinander
setzten sich bis auf den obersten der
deckel bleibt ganz jetzt nehmt ihr
entweder einen ausstecher glas und
könnte mit einem messer scheiben oder
ihnen zum beispiel einen tortenring
[Musik]
und gleichzeitig eine torte
da streiche ich jetzt das abgekühlte
orientiert drauf und wenn ihr das nicht
machen wollt könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
eine marmelade
[Musik]
dann hab ich jetzt hier die weiße
schokoladencreme die habe ich in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt und habe hier vorne
eine große loch thüle und so kann ich
die torte richtig gut einstreichen
also einfach so und die creme
gleichmäßig platzieren
[Musik]
dann den zweiten boden drauf
und jetzt müsst ihr natürlich die mitte
mit einer überraschung für das tier
jelly belly ist in ganz bunten schönen
farben ihr könnt auch smarties nehmen
oder andere süßigkeiten die er gerne
habt und die kommunizieren der mitte
[Musik]
und die celli belize oder die
süßigkeiten einfach so weit sein film
dass es schön eben ist mit dem
trockenboden wenn er nämlich zu wenig
habt dann geht der tortenboden eben auch
in die tiefe und da jetzt auch wieder
die creme rein und dann die torte schön
verschließen mit dem deckel
[Musik]
und damit die torte schön gerade wird
setzt sich jetzt hier einen trockenen
retter drauf und kühl sie jetzt erstmal
für mindestens ein bis zwei stunden
und dann kam sehr schön gestrichen
werden jetzt wird die torte
eingestrichen
ich habe übrigens noch einen trocken
ring drumrum gesetzt damit die torte
richtig schön gerade wird an den rändern
jetzt einfach die übrigen zehn neben den
rand und die oberfläche einstreichen
[Musik]
wer dann mit der torte zufrieden seid
kommt jetzt noch mal in die kühlung
dieses mal stelle ich sie allerdings in
den gefrierschrank damit sie ein
bisschen fest wird für den trip so etwa
für eine stunde
falls ihr kein platz im gefrierschrank
habt dann kommt einfach die tore zu etwa
zwei bis drei stunden in den kühlschrank
den trip habe ich ihr ziel die weiße
schokolade die ich freuen bereits
gegeben habe sind 200 gramm und 100
gramm sahne die das tier kurz aufkochen
also der trick wird auch im prinzip mit
einer garage gemacht jetzt die sahne vom
herunterziehen
[Musik]
und dann schön verrühren damit sich
alles schön auf jetzt könnt ihr hier
jede beliebige farbe einräumt ich nehme
jetzt ein bisschen blau erlebnis mit dem
verpasste und das solltet ihr jetzt auch
war passte nehmen den flüssige farbe die
wird einfach die konsistenz dieses trips
zu sehr verändern
und fast ist eben auch immer schön
ergebnis und deswegen nehme ich sie ganz
gerne
[Musik]
seht schon kommen eine richtig schöne
farbe zustande
und dadurch dass die schokolade ja so
einen gelbstich hat wird es nun richtig
schön ist es nicht es riecht es noch ein
bisschen und lass es leicht abkühlen
damit sap einfach nicht zu warm ist für
die sahnetorte meine torte ist schön
angefroren und die garage ist jetzt
ungefähr hand waren also so etwa 32 grad
wenn ihr mit kleidung finger rein geht
und sie ist nicht mehr hat und nicht
mehr warm kann das ist eigentlich ganz
gut
und jetzt nimmt er einen löffel und last
erst einmal dieser spitzen und die nasen
hier am rand runter laufen so ein
bisschen gezielt und dann kommt der rest
auf die oberfläche
[Musik]
da wohl noch ein bisschen trip fehlt
könnte er immer noch ein bisschen was
drauf setzen und dadurch dass die torte
ein bisschen an gefroren ist wird der
trip jetzt auch relativ schnell fest
dann habt ihr den größten teil der torte
schon geschafft und jetzt kann ich die
2009/10 oben rein stecken und hier habe
ich noch ein bisschen konfetti damit der
korrekt oder fertig
[Musik]
kleiner schönheitsfehler die korrigiere
ich jetzt nur ich habe ich zum beispiel
einen kleinen skopje blättchen nämlich
einen zahnstocher weg und hier hatte ich
die zahlen nicht ganz mittig
reingesteckt und da habe ich jetzt
einfach ein bisschen von der garage
spritze hilft es war nichts überstürzen
und einfach so ein bisschen was dran
machen
[Musik]
was aber jetzt schon vor ich habe auch
eine andere sind jetzt fertig ok ich
werde mir noch besser
die meerjungfrau woche die so passiert
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es kommt die silvesterpartys investor
torte kunst noch mal machen wir gemacht
sowohl kreislauf ich habe jetzt noch mal
rein
hier kommt die semester torte
anschneiden was nochmal an wo ich
befürchte dass die zahl um gibt werde
ich jetzt abschneide hat mit dem
innenleben zu tun
[Musik]
ich hoffe die zahlen fragt nicht raus
bereich hast du noch flüssig
heute probiere ich dachte also mms oder
so zu
und dann kamen die fenster damit
gerechnet es ist ja man kann schnell
oder das kaputte meisten schokolade
mitmachst abholen
ich hatte übrigens keine gabel ich jetzt
ein ende haben
das macht man nicht gut zum nachmachen
empfohlen
also vielleicht sauer was für eure
silvesterparty wenn ja dann probiert aus
macht ein foto und verlinkt mich auf
eurem foto dann sehe ich es auch und wir
wünschen euch jetzt schon mal richtig
schönes silvesterfeier eine richtig
schöne silvester feiern und ein schönes
neues jahr
bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]